They're titans of the comic book movie world — but
are Kevin Feige and James Gunn
destined to be friends… or foes?
DC shocked Hollywood when they announced that
James Gunn and Peter Safran had been tapped to
lead DC Studios, overseeing film, television,
and animation for the comic book giant. Gunn,
being one of the few people to have
worked with both Marvel and DC,
is revered by comic fans for his
work on Guardians of the Galaxy,
The Suicide Squad, and Peacemaker. In a
joint statement, Gunn and Safran said:
"We're honored to be the stewards of
these DC characters we've loved since
we were children. [...] We're excited to
invigorate the theatrical experience around
the world as we tell some of the biggest, most
beautiful, and grandest stories ever told."
Hopefully, Gunn will be able to turn
around the struggling DC Extended Universe,
which appears to have been renamed the "DC
Universe." When Gunn posted the news to Twitter,
he was inundated with congratulations
from fans and celebrities alike.
Fans naturally started making demands
almost immediately, from Justice League
sequels to Poison Ivy and Harley Quinn
romances — and everything in between.
But Gunn still has one foot in Marvel's door
even as he makes his move to DC. So how does
the head of the MCU, Kevin Feige, feel about
the announcement? In an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter at the premiere
of Black Panther: Wakanda Forever,
Kevin Feige commented on James Gunn's
ascension to the head of DC Studios.
Unsurprisingly, the MCU czar had nothing but
kind things to say about Gunn's promotion,
and he insisted he's still working
closely with Gunn on the MCU.
"We have a wonderful thing called The Guardians
of the Galaxy Holiday Special coming out. We
have a wonderful thing called Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3 coming out in May."
Feige also voiced some light-hearted
concern about Gunn's scheduling:
"How he'll have any time to work
on DC until May I don't know,
but once he does have the time I'll be
very excited. I'll be first in line."
Feige and Gunn insist that there is
no rivalry between the two studios,
and the two seem to be as friendly as they
ever were. But that hasn't stopped fans on
social media from pitting the two studio heads
against each other. One Twitter user wrote:
"Kevin Feige accidentally creating his own arch
nemesis is such a beautiful comic book arc."
Others commended Feige on his professionalism
in praising Gunn, with one tweeting:
"Kevin Feige might be one of my [favorite] people
ever. It's so wholesome to see him unconditionally
be a Marvel Studios alum's number one
fan, even if it's for a rival studio."
That being said, Gunn's relationship with
Disney wasn't always as peachy as it is now.
Back in 2018, the company fired Gunn for
some old, offensive tweets that were dug
up by conservatives angered by Gunn's
opposition to Donald Trump. The social
media posts were dug up by conservative media
outlet The Daily Caller in response to Gunn's
outspoken criticism of the then-president.
The tweets in question were posted in 2008
and 2009. Alan Horn, chair of Walt
Disney Studios at the time, said:
"The offensive attitudes and statements discovered
on James' Twitter feed are indefensible and
inconsistent with our studio's values, and we
have severed our business relationship with him."
It's worth noting that, in a 2021
interview with The Hollywood Reporter,
Gunn said that Horn's decision was as much of a
shock to Kevin Feige as it was to anybody else.
In a now-deleted tweet, Gunn responded
that, in the early days of his career,
he thought of himself as a "provocateur," often
telling jokes that were "outrageous and taboo."
He also claimed to have grown as a person since
making those jokes. According to Deadline,
the public apology that Gunn made and
his contrite attitude throughout the
whole process led to Marvel rehiring Gunn.
Horn met with Gunn on several occasions to
discuss the incident and seemed to think that
the director was truly sorry for his tweets.
Evidently, Gunn seems to have won
fans' trust over the years too,
and most people seem to be perfectly
happy with his new position. What his
promotion means for the DCU,
however, remains to be seen.